des figaro magazine dès demain on va
aller en italie où le nouveau
gouvernement a prêté serment ce matin et
dans la foulée le premier conseil des
ministres alors dont la vue on l'a pu
lire dans le figaro ce matin la gauche
raflent tous les portefeuilles sont
importants pour l'europe notamment
l'économie les finances et les relations
avec bruxelles
les cinq étoiles e conserve dix
ministères dont celui des affaires
étrangères particularité y sera occupée
par le leader 5 étoiles luigi di maio et
particularité ils ne parlent pas anglais
ceci dit ça n'effraie pas pour autant
amélie de montchanin qui elle s'est dit
plutôt rassuré même pas plutôt qui s'est
carrément rassuré par ce nouveau
gouvernement ce nouveau gouvernement
c'est en tout cas ce qu'elle a confié à
guillaume durand sur radio classique ce
qui est une bonne chose c'est que la
crise italienne ait pu être résolu ce
qui est une bonne chose c'est que
l'italie va pouvoir construire un budget
je crois que la clé cette affaire c'est
qu'ils puissent construire un budget
dans des conditions normales parce que
le risque que faisait prendre salvinia
son pays c'est que si son plan s'était
déroulé comme il le voulait il n'y
aurait pas eu de gouvernement que pour
avoir un budget et vous savez comme moi
qu'un pays sans budget c'est un pays qui
n'a plus de police publics sont appelés
qui devient dysfonctionnel et toi est ce
que vous êtes rassurés marque quand vous
voyez ce gouvernement comme les milliers
de manchots
oui de montchanin et naturellement
optimiste mois par dix ans d'espérance
de vie en plus c'est très bien mais le
plus jeune de lui comme moi de -15 ans
donc ça effectivement
moi je suis parent structure de
pessimistes parce que vous ne gagnez ce
que je suis journaliste
donc c'est mon métier que tu achètes je
sais pas franchement je sais pas si on
peut être objectif en tout cas je pense
que il ya des fêtes qui parle pour spu
pour l'italie les deux mouvements qui
sont aujourd'hui pouvoir le cinq étoiles
est il parti démocrate se sont jamais
entendus et toujours combattu ceci dit
les deux précédents avant ils ont tenu
14 mois je pense que c'est le talent de
nous était compté le premier ministre
que d'essayer de faire l'alchimie
l'alliance donc on verra bien combien de
temps ça durera
visiblement ils ont quand même un accord
sur 26 points que les points principaux
notamment sur l'économie et
l'immigration
et surtout ils ont enlevé un petit peu
les têtes d'affiché je dirais des têtes
à claques ou les têtes de gondole
effectivement ils ont mis au ministère
de l'intérieur pour traiter les
questions très importantes d'immigration
et de flux migratoire en méditerranée
la préfète de milan qui est une femme
sans étiquette qui on peut dire quand
même que c'est pas du tout le même
casting que son prédécesseur selvini
donc on voit vraiment que le nouveau
gouvernement veut temporiser surtout pas
mettre une tête à claques ou de mettre
de l'huile sur le feu par rapport à son
prédécesseur salvini et puis là je
trouve que la deuxième décision qui pose
plutôt qui pousse plutôt à l'optimisme
selene de la proposition de nomination
de l'ancien premier ministre john key
l'oni comme aux commissaires quelqu'un
de unanimement appréciée unanimement
recommandée par l'ensemble de la classe
politique italienne et donc ces deux
signes d'apaisement et plutôt qui montre
que le
ça va dans le bon sens par rapport à ce
qu'on a connu et par rapport aux 14 mois
qui ont été cette alliance complètement
surréaliste entre cinq étoiles et la
ligue du nord la série des têtes à
claques matteo renzi qui se mettrait en
retrait matteo renzi qui était
l'épouvantail idéal pour les électeurs
du mouvement 5 étoiles matteo salvini la
discipline est d'ailleurs c'est le
dernier livre que qui vient d'être qui
vient de sortir justement une première
biographie écrite par une journaliste
française qui s'appelle marie d'armagnac
et qu'on voit aux commandes c'est très
intéressant vous apprendrez d'ailleurs
que le leader de l'extrême droite
italienne ne vient pas non pas des
milieux nostalgiques de messieurs l'ine
mais des milieux anarchistes et sécher
l'artilleur mathieu guillaume roquette
souligne dans son édito ce week end du
film hague que ce retournement de
coalition est intervenue sans que les
intérêts les électeurs aient été
consultés et même si un début bien un
programme acords en 26 points ya pas
quand même véritablement de programme
commun il ya une consultation pour
répondre à l'édito de guillaume il ya
quand même une consultation alors je
sais plus quelle avait été les modalités
d'organisation de cette consultation est
elle dit d'ailleurs quelque chose de
notre vie démocratique nations
numériques aux aînés aux membres aux
sympathisants 2,5 et 3,5 est absolument
ils sont plus nombreux à avoir voté ce
coup-ci que l'année dernière l'année
dernière ils avaient été consultés je
crois qu'ils avaient été un peu moins de
70 milles où je sais plus combien enfin
à avoir approuvé à 75%
l'alliance avec la ligue les mêmes ou à
peu près alors plus nombreux à voter à
80% ont émis un avis favorable à la
licence cette fois ci avec le parti
démocrate
donc la démocratie ça dit que en un an
le même le même échantillon on peut dire
tout et son contraire
ensuite on voit donc que les populistes
en fait font eux mêmes les preuves de ce
qu'est la vie démocratique
je dirais que de ce point de vue là
c'est assez rassurant on voit que quand
des populistes prospère en faisant la
critique de la démocratie et que serait
qu'il se retrouve ensuite aux manettes
de la démocratie comme les autres en
fait ils butent sur un certain nombre
d'écueils et de difficultés la bonne
nouvelle on peut se poser la question de
savoir jusqu'où tout cela va nous mener
et si cette coalition va tenir de façon
plus solide que celle qui lui pressé
mais la bonne nouvelle c'est quand même
que matteo salvini dont on peut quand
même penser assez facilement le plus
grand mal n'est plus aux affaires et
donc la résultante mais de tout cela c
est et salvini par ailleurs s'est planté
tout seul il c'est sur la plage tirer
tout seul en fait ce sera leur pièce que
nous dit ce que nous dit cette
internaute la stratégie de salvini a
échoué cette alliance de gauche
par contre ne changera pas grand chose à
la politique du pays pense-t-il sauf sur
la communication qui sera plus et j'ai
ajouté un dernier élément pendant très
longtemps la ligue et le mouvement 5
étoiles n'était pas du tout sur la même
ligne et je dirais même que quelques
semaines avant la coalition de l'année
dernière ils n'étaient pas aux yeux de
beaucoup de gens plausible qu'il puisse
se réunir et à l'époque lors leurs
programmes électoraux étaient quasi
antinomiques
bon ils ont ri il avait réussi il ya un
an a passé un accord qui n'est pas
nécessairement moins baroque plus
baroque que celui qui est passé
aujourd'hui avec le parti des essais
c'est pas que ça dure et autant ont
certes tenu 14 mois bon il ya un non dit
qui revient quand on parle de l'italie
qui n'est pas notre gouvernement c'est
le celui de salvini france nice en
salvini l'italie va suivre la grèce à
moins qu'ils ne retournent vers la chine
esi l'italie qualité si tu le dis soit
les italiens recommence à accueillir les
migrants et le gouvernement va chuter
dans les sondages soit il continue et
lieu va essayer de les bloquer un
maximum pour vous de votre point de vue
une italie sans selvini c'est mieux pour
la gestion des flux migratoires c'est
mieux pour la gestion des flux
migratoires en tout cas c'est la
possible de la question je ne sais que
c'est la possibilité cette fois-ci de
trouver un accord européen ou en tout
cas avec un certain nombre de pays
européens pour faire en sorte que
l'italie ne supporte pas tout seul les
arrivées
migratoire parce que ce qui a fait la
force de sa vie n'est ce qu'ils avaient
fait l'échec du gouvernement précédent
c'est la difficulté pour les pays
européens à mettre en place un mécanisme
de répartition et donc je pense que ce
gouvernement enfin si j'ai bien compris
va de nouveau accepté la règle de la mer
c'est-à-dire d'accueillir les bateaux au
premier port sûr et très souvent ce sera
l'italie ou malte
mais l'enjeu pour les européens c'est
c'est d'arriver à voir un mécanisme de
répartition du reste vous noterez je ne
sais pas si vous avez vu mais que la
france accélère les arrivées à partir de
l'italie des personnes qui ont qui ont
débarqué le clos fillon on prend en
charge de manière beaucoup plus rapide
parce qu'il ya un accord avec plusieurs
pays les migrants qui arrivent mais
l'enjeu et ça va être difficile tant
pour les italiens que pour l'ensemble
des européens qui c'est le fait que sur
les bateaux
une partie de ceux qui sont qui arrive
ne sont pas aux besoins de protection au
sens de la convention de genève et donc
tout l'enjeu depuis des mois c'est
qu'est ce qu'on fait de ceux qui ne sont
pas en besoin de protection
est ce qu'il ya un mécanisme de
répartition la première nationalité qui
a des bases sur le besoin de protection
ça veut dire des gens qui seront
reconnus par l'ofpra comme pouvant
bénéficier du statut de réfugié fera
perdre que la première nationalité qui a
débarqué en italie
l'année dernière ce sont les tunisiens
et que dans tous les bateaux vous avez
certes c'est pas c'est pas considérée
comme un pays c'est tout c'est tout
l'enjeu c'est à dire que est ce que les
personnes qui arrivent aux dés lors
qu'elle ne bénéficieront pas du statut
de réfugié elles sont quand même
répartie entre plusieurs pays européens
ou est ce qu elles sont laissées en
italie ou à malte et c'est ça la
difficulté depuis le début
donc on va voir comment les choses se
passent mais c'est vrai qu'avoir une
technicienne comme ministre de
l'intérieur c'est quand même sans doute
beaucoup plus facile que d'avoir un
hyper politiques qui instrumentalisent
la question mais la question de fond
elle reste et vous remarquerez que c'est
un sujet sur lequel l'europe et
particulièrement divisée à chaque fois
qu'il ya des relocalisations à partir de
malte ou de l'italie il n'ya jamais
dix pays qui acceptent de prendre les
les migrants alors qu'il ya
théoriquement 27 pays et c'est toujours
entre l'allemagne la france la france
est le premier pays à accueillir les
relocaliser avec avec l'allemagne et
puis on a le portugal on va aller à
l'espagne un peu mais la roumanie un peu
ces derniers temps
oui c'est ça l'enjeu est donc s'il n'y a
pas une capacité à retravailler et avec
l'italie qui soit en même temps compris
par la population italienne a bien
évidemment à la fin on peut dire que
malheureusement cette vie ni peut
revenir et il a et il y a un enjeu
extrêmement important j'ajoute que les
questions budgétaires ne sont pas minces
mais là il ya des spécialistes
beaucoup plus que moi mais la
préparation du prochain budget de savoir
si les européens acceptent ou pas qu'il
ya un déficit plus important que les 3%
des critères de maastricht que comme
vous le rappeliez gens personnellement a
souvent stigmatisé un et bien c'est un
enjeu important pour savoir si sa venue
pour revenir plus fort ou pas on peut
toutefois supposer que échaudés par une
année très difficile avec l'italie avec
les représentants du gouvernement
italien
l'europe se montre un peu plus
constructive sur effectivement les deux
sujets que sont les questions
migratoires est par ailleurs la question
des finances publiques puis ce serait
assez malin sud ensuite si je voulais
une baffe ne va pas forcément faciliter
le débat alors que si je veux si je fais
pas le geste ça sera plus facile
emmanuel dans l'opinion ce changement
l'italie ce ça rassure ça inquiète dans
l'opinion française
franchement aujourd'hui j'en sais rien
je sais juste qu'on n'aimait pas du tout
matteo salvini que le voir dégagé sera
probablement un soulagement vous dis
maillot étant beaucoup moins beaucoup
moins connus ce qui va falloir recruter
c'est l'opinion italienne et notamment
ceux des électeurs du du mouvement à 5
étoiles c'était très juste de rappeler
qu'il n'était pas aligné les électeurs
n'étaient pas alignés non plus avec les
électeurs de salvini et c'est pour ça
que le mouvement 5 étoiles d'ailleurs
entre les élections générales du mois
d'avril 2018 et les élections
européennes font passer de 31 à 17 %
les électeurs n'ont pas aimé que ce soit
salvini finalement qui incarne la ligne
directrice à laquelle avec leur vote ils
avaient contribué à ces questions partie
des électeurs de cinq étoiles sont
partis chez solly a je crois qu'ils sont
maintenant ils sont d'ailleurs en partie
retourner et beaucoup d'électeurs de
gauche en fait dans le mouvement 5
étoiles antisystème exaspérés par la
corruption par un spectacle politique on
a connu ça ailleurs d'ailleurs mais qui
reste des électeurs de gauche qui ont
noté ces salles toute la question c'est
de savoir si les 17 % qui restent eux
vont être excès créé par une coalition
avec le parti le parti démocrate
là il ya des paris qui sont pris un pari
perdu par salvini et un pari tenté et je
pense que effectivement beaucoup de gens
doivent savoir ça en tête pour se dire
non pas qu est-ce qui fait fonctionner
avec l'italie mais qu'est ce qui peut
faire que cette coalition soit pas
immédiatement lâché parce qu'il
emportait vous voir cette coalition a
quand même une épine dans le pied
c'est la sphère du milan turin de lyon
turin de la ligne à grande vitesse lyon
turin
ça fait partie du grand absent mais
c'est sûr ça c'est parce qu'il ya eu un
vote contradictoire entre cinq étoiles
et le parti démocrate que matteo salvini
a pensé que c'était son heure mais c'est
un sujet important parce que faut quand
même se rappeler que la base électorale
est essentielle de la ligue c'est quand
même le nord 1 sur la question
économique et le lyon turin est une
question importante d'un point de vue
économique pour le nord en tout cas
soutenu par le patronat du nord et sur
la question migratoire la base de matteo
salvini potentiel c'est la question
migratoire
donc il ya là quelque chose qui est pas
facile bon donc je rappelle le livre un
matteo salvini l'indiscipliné donc c'est
celle artilleurs essai signé marie
d'armagnac la première biographie
française sur le leader de l'extrême
droite italienne